and I will say that there's this dog
characters in the film yeah um I'm not
one new likes at all seeing a dog get
killed in a film I'm not saying whether
or not that happens I'm saying that that
movie actually got me to the point where
I was like I think you gotta kill this
guy there's another thing where I feel
like I'm I feel like he knows we love ya
so Stephen Lang plays bane meets
daredevil yeah
Bane little bear down there gregory's
the name of this guy with a shaved head
sort of and they call me the John the
John Justice of the John John just came
back from watching don't breathe I saw
it a couple days ago I refused to talk
about with this movie with anyone else
but Shawn Humphrey John what did you
think please let me know he is the
social media manager of facebook.com
slash Blue House let's see what the
horror movie guy thinks I just got out
of this like an hour like an hour and a
half ago so I'm still kind of
rearranging my my brains from this but
well I had a fantastic time I was really
impressed like I I really liked fede
alvarez already like full disclosure
like panic attack is is pretty cool and
Evil Dead I was dazzled by this is
another step forward he's showing what
else he can do you know with all those
chops I've seen Evil Dead remake I've
seen all of from dusk till dawn so
seeing all the episodes he shot and I
saw this and I would say that my honest
and professional opinion that this is
his most well crafted film he's ever
done this is tight man la like there's
some gory stuff in here not too gory and
there's some like gross out moments but
not too much there's a wide hero
and very uncomfortable one of my first
things that I thought went out when this
movie was done was how impressed I was
with how fatty Albers is previous where
that scene had like a pretty good amount
of gore and violence especially the Evil
Dead remake why said he really doesn't
rely on that here in terms of crafting
this I cinematographer Pedro Luque I
think it's a bouquet who Luke I don't
know this speak Spanish I don't speak
Spanish the film they crafted together
here is kind of reminiscent sort of a
film more like panic room in a way yeah
it is it is a home invasion movie in a
sense I like films of consequence like
no one's really a good guy in this movie
yeah and I like a film where everyone's
essentially an antihero and you're
watching stories of bad people play out
it's just bad meets worse Sam Raimi
produced this I think of a movie drag me
to hell like Alison Lohman character how
she had to make a decision that was a
major consequence towards her life and
here they're making a decision diliman
that's character he's the voice of
reason he's the voice of going like we
shouldn't do this or so many illegal
things that we could get caught off or
yeah like he knows the law and he's the
he's they all have a very different role
in this little crime trio and he's the
guy like when we meet them they're doing
these crimes that weren't about money
they're very carefully planned out and
he's kind of keeping them in check most
of this movie takes place when they
deviate from that way yeah Jane levy or
levy whatever rocky in the film rocky
she plays be ready actually has a little
sister that she wants to take care of
that was a really great backdrop cuz
this is a very immediate movie this is a
movie that gives you it's three
characters in this situation they're in
and and we kind of go from there and I
don't think that's a bad thing it's like
you don't spend all of your life I'm
telling people all the details of who
yeah like this movie takes place in a
window and they set it in Detroit which
is a very specific backdrop and it's
like there aren't very many people
around it you can feel how rundown
everything is and you get why these
three people are doing this yeah there's
there's a world here there's a there's a
gloom the
there's a real specific mood throughout
it's a weird film yeah it doesn't try to
sell you at all but this is a normal
regular world and this weird thing
happens it starts off like this is
there's something sinister at play yeah
I mean and it's in the room and it's in
the presence of every shot none of us
are living very well this is not a part
of the country that is being taken care
of at all and and we got a Rob's a life
that makes the leads at least you know
interesting because yeah you could argue
that they're unlikable I mean till a
minute of all of them is the most like
Oh like he's yeah sure Ruby
even if they're unlikable you kind of
get their circumstances and that makes
it more dimensional for me anyway yeah
the only character who I didn't think
was the best red and Daniel's Lovato's
character money money yeah like I got it
I could see the intention of what the
writing was going for in terms of that
character like yeah he's supposed to be
kind of stupid he's supposed to be kind
of dumb well there's something about it
where I felt like I don't necessarily
blame the actors choice on it it was for
me it really was more of the writing it
seemed like an actor who doesn't behave
like this guy at all was playing this
guy you know I like for a performance
like that I would have liked to have
seen a performance from like that guy
the way how we really didn't realize as
opposed to I could tell this person
probably doesn't have that kind of
accent and his voice probably doesn't
carry himself that way at all like I get
it seem like a performance to me every
year shows he was killed off pretty
early and that moment the way they shot
that moment was like there's a nice
addition because even the trailer it's a
jump-scare yeah in the trailer but then
they add a little something to it that
they couldn't show in the trailer that
is really it's a cool shot Oh [ __ ]
sick shot yeah see that wasn't as much
of a problem for me actually I thought
he did a good job with this - I mean he
is of all of them in the group he's the
guy who wants to be a tough guy gangster
you know and that's kind of all he's
about or that's all we get into his life
and and I didn't find it very unnatural
I guess I can see how you how you might
yeah I mean I did a decent job I just
say I just thought that was the only
part of the writing that I had issues
with Stephen Lang the set up of his
characters great yeah how he does just
seem like a
old helpless oh my god yeah man living
this horribly sad yes yeah yeah rundown
house in a neighborhood nobody else
lives in anymore honestly like a lot of
people I some people have even ruined
the file moment in their non-spoiler
reviews I think a moment that really
stood out to me was the opening shot of
this film I figure some people really
[ __ ] in yeah boy the opening shot you
see Stephen Lang dragging Jane's body
through the street and she's all beaten
up and [ __ ] and then it cuts back to you
like what happened earlier yeah so we
don't know exactly if that's the ending
and they all lose or some like we don't
know what's gonna happen exactly this is
but you you know it's not good to go
well the entire time and then actually
they really added cuz that first I was
like why would they show you that I was
really questioning yeah like why would
why would if any Albertus choose to have
that moment in the opening yeah but as
the film progressed I saw that really
added to detention cuz these guys really
think it's gonna go smoothly yeah but we
know like not gonna go smooth guys and
if you just waiting for it to get worse
and there are even moments like you you
know what's gonna haven't you've seen
the trailer but they're even moments
earlier where you're like no maybe this
could ya stop forgetting about that
opening specific have your sequence
you're like maybe there may be none of
the protagonists will win in the end
yeah it does a good job of that that
opening moment you know could have
fallen flat in in lesser hands but it
does a good job making you know you
remember it and you wonder how on earth
are we gonna get there yeah exactly so
it am sup the mystery in an amps up the
tension and and they just throw in other
surprises to to distract you from that
yeah that's what I mean like this story
is so gripping need the immediate effect
of everything's so gripping you forget
that that opening scene showed that
Steven Lee is probably gonna like
dominate their books Pacific adventures
is [ __ ] intense you know some people
have a very complain about like there
are some people I saw a movie with
they're a conical Playa belly
there's no way black guy can do hey I
don't buy that this guy was from the
Army and he was a trained fighter and
this guy was clearly like a vet like you
know he's like in his 60s he still keeps
in shape clearly waiting like when he
had all his senses he clearly had them
home
the action and when I got into daredevil
I started researching to see like just
how far a blind guy and their other
senses can advance now no scientific
evidence pointed that daredevil is
possible to it yeah but this level of
Stephen Lang totally capable like that's
not something where I'm like this is
ridiculous they did a lot of brain
studies where it does show that when you
lose your sight your brain rewires
itself to amplify the other senses to
allow you to survive in this world yeah
your chemistry of your brain I do
believe does actually change cuz the
parts of your brain that usually go to
your site or whatever you have ya lose
they just get redistributed elsewhere
and what I liked a lot were the details
that they threw in because as he's
moving throughout the house they take
time to show you him like reaching up to
find certain things certain touch stones
that he's left around and and feeling
out and and you can tell that he's
looking for something specific he's not
just kind of feeling the walls it's like
if I can touch this at least I read it
like if he can touch this and know what
it is okay now I know where I am in the
house did you look who's lived in this
house and and hasn't come out for five
days and usually does bad just even
laying I heard that when he filmed this
he had to wear a context that really did
make him blind
which is pluggin sweet he's terrified I
mean like I don't think everyone is
willing to make a movie like this
because there are moments there long
there's a long shot during one of those
fights between him and Jane levy where
it's like a rough fight and he's I don't
know you know if they had his context
and for them but they both went for it
like you know the struggle and it's
nasty and there are moments too that are
so well choreographed it's like when
Stephen Lang sometimes like punches
these people in this shots it could look
like the really getting hit and jeno he
was actually like couldn't see yeah
while filming that [ __ ] is so scary to
me whoever did the insurance means
movies probably losing their mind the
way this film plays out it's like
watching a game one folder I remember
like when they first break into the home
they have it is kind of similar to panic
room actually where they have this shot
where it's going through the whole home
yeah you see the details and certain
hidden
I remember faking like oh this is it the
game is about to begin and we're
watching our players play and and fede
alvarez I felt treated his direction of
the film like that like you're watching
this game on a mystery on oh yeah yeah
it's a really it's like a well-crafted
suspense thriller for sure when you
watch them when you watch the trailer
and I had a couple of thoughts of like I
feel like you could easily get this well
thought out to where there we go okay
well Steven Lang's motivation would then
be to do this to keep them closed it
like how does he keep them trapped now
so the way everything is done just
hasn't all makes sense well and there's
something about movies like this where
it does fall on the actors and what the
director chooses to do because you can
easily make a movie like this where the
complaint would be valid like you these
people were all stupid and this guy they
could totally kill this guy but the way
they sell you know the hesitations and
the panics and the the sheer terror of
knowing this guy doing them like what I
got a totally go against is the argument
of people saying like there was so many
times it could have killed Steven link
the reason they took the moments that
they could yeah there were moments where
they did try a B the moments where they
didn't make sense at the time in the
movie especially because of Dylan
Manette's point of view when he finds
out that Daniels Lovato brought a gun
there's a whole moment where he's just
like what though but we're gonna go to
prison for like 10 years if we get cut
to see the con so you know that they're
not gonna think we should kill this guy
cuz I could just make everything worse
in terms of them possibly getting caught
there's constantly more on the line than
just that especially for Jane levy and
by extension FERC for doing Manette
you know money just once his money you
can see why it's not just so easy as
well yeah we'll just kill him yeah we
shouldn't be here in the first place
especially when they essentially don't
need to and like you could see how it's
hard to kill him - yeah well and even
money I like that to keep in money's not
ready to do it like you could tell the
whole time and I thought that was a
brilliant scene you know I like thinking
about the movie now I might be going
back on my first opinion about him
because that scene especially it really
does show that this guy was just a poser
yeah it's like he's not gonna and I'm
sitting there going I'm Stephen Lang
like he's yeah he was a soldier like
he knows this guy's not gonna do [ __ ]
and he's gonna disarm him right now yeah
yeah and that and it's those those
subtle character moments that really add
a lot to this movie because like I said
it is immediate and we don't learn tons
about everyone's backstory but like the
way they do the characters is really
effective first off what downs of auto
yeah actually make all the things I was
saying all the choices makes sense now
because he's posing yeah so that
actually makes sense yeah but when it
comes to a certain extent he's not that
tough yeah you know he's not a killer
I buy that the whole thing of how like
Steven Lane was a little strip the gun
away from him and everything like oh you
cuz he knows you know not just knows the
fighting but like he can also pick up
just on the guy's tone Sam's meaning
that there's a beer in a trap
additionally and he's done with enough
like violence in his life to know if
someone's really gonna pull a trigger
the crazy twist like towards the end
I thought work was really well done yeah
you know cuz if that could have gone
like this is ridiculous and it kind of
does go with your ridiculous territory
but it adds yeah yeah I do have to get
used to it for a second because cuz when
that twist first starts to that big sort
of plot turn starts to unfold I I was
taken aback at personally what is
happening it sells it you know it sells
it for it sells it for why he has such
an extreme situation I'm not letting
these intruders break out yeah I mean
this is a this is a guy who's been
through you know battle and and intense
military training and also probably some
crazy PTSD I'm sure this is a [ __ ] up
individual I have no problem
understanding why he was doing what he
was doing yeah I know issues doing it I
think in terms of just plot alone it
totally adds to all this because if it
was just about money he would have just
let them [ __ ] I think Steven Leight
would have been a lot more lenient about
just what about not trying so hard yeah
to let these people escape and kill them
because there's a lot more going on than
just money
you know and it adds a whole other
dimension it really is like you broke
into the wrong yeah there's a reason
this dude is still in this yeah no one
else is here this dude's here what a
blind guy who chillin in such a
beat-down oh man
[ __ ] Detroit is evil crazy dog and
Jane leaving man I think she's [ __ ]
terrific in this movie she's a great I
want to see anything she's in cuz she's
so natural and she's she's really great
at selling these roles and really making
nuanced choices as an actress she's very
she makes she makes very real choices I
think her and Dillman Ned's is such a
great job in these roles it didn't allow
themselves to fall into cliche territory
when it's so easily start like the set
up of this stuff is kind of smart
because I like how fede alvarez is kind
of having fun with you okay that's what
I mean about the director playing a game
with the audience and it's it's very
clever it's more than just watching a
suspenseful thriller and you can feel
the director having fun like he knows
how [ __ ] weird this [ __ ] and that's
something I really enjoyed about Evil
Dead 2 is like that movie is a lot
darker and a lot more mean than the
original yeah but but it's also kind of
hilarious like you can tell like someone
behind that camera is having a lot of
this the same way how Evil Dead sets up
like here's a normal thing that's going
to have you actually this girl's going
through her withdrawals and everything
but the friends are just gonna hang on
at the cab that's get any fun but then
shit's gonna go crazy but it's gonna go
[ __ ] crazy
yeah it's not just gonna go bad it's
gonna go insane this movie is gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of its character and that's
what this movie does to like like you
see these guys pull off a small little
job at first and you're like okay these
guys know what they're doing this should
be a walk in the bar but no it's gonna
go bad but it's not just gonna go bad
it's gonna go [ __ ] insane and I look
there's a one specific gross out moment
where everyone in the audience was just
like and I was that film analytical guy
going
no one even some of the dialogue in that
seat like it knows what you're thinking
and it knows just how uncomfortable you
all right now okay tell you what
once you're having this video we'll do
an extra two minutes talking about when
I was I was impressed with Dylan Manette
in this - because he's a he's an
interesting actor to me because uh I
really like goosebumps and I liked him
minute and he's a guy were like every
time I see him he keeps winning me
because like he's so perfect looking
this is this is just like a it's not an
actual criticism he's like he's so
perfect looking like there's something
about it where I'm always surprised that
I'm so engaged by yeah I'm like you look
like a perfect kind of TV ish you know
Giroux Bukh face and yet I'm really
engrossed by this performance in this
you know and and I really like to me
goosebumps do very different but you
know I'm always like oh this guy and
then he always impresses me or at least
he has both times when it gets to the
point where everyone in the movie is not
having a good day and everyone's looking
pretty pretty spent like there's a harsh
contrast it was cool about Dillman is
he's acting has like this like he's
good-looking but kind of like that dorky
look he's got a boyish you know there's
like Jake Gyllenhaal but then there's
his look-alike Tobey Maguire he has a
boyish Tobey Maguire it isn't exactly
yeah it was like the boy thing but he
has this like really deep voice that
just makes him like manly what I'm glad
he got a role like this cuz he could be
playing you know he could easily be
playing you know like a cool high school
guy who's kind of sensitive I'm psyched
that he popped up in a movie like this
man I really enjoyed his chemistry with
Jane levy because the writing really
contributes a lot to this film sets you
up in like this is gonna go down
directions that are probably gonna go
this way that's what I mean by that by
the director having fun
the setup is more than just good things
gonna happen but - it's gonna happen
yeah
it sets you up in a way where you're
like bold this is gonna happen with this
character these you're gonna do like you
think you know how it's gonna play out
in the end what arcs these characters
are gonna have but no it's uh it's a
different film this is what happens when
everybody has their own plan and no no
the whole night and when they shot with
the night visions in my vision sequence
like it's not like really define night
vision cuz you kind of have to like on
that green you have to focus to make
sure you see what's going on - yeah they
use that's a great offense yeah because
they've caught they cause the audience
to be involved and go okay yeah and I
really feel like they shot that in the
dark
cuz those actors really seemed like they
couldn't see it really looks like no you
have any Alvers you probably would have
done something like that yeah and it
seems like these are all actors who are
very willing to throw themselves into
their roles I bet that they yeah I did
cuz that that also looked like it would
would have been really cool to be on set
for and I have no real complaints about
this movie excluding excluding the last
like two minutes of this film okay and
I'll save that to you for after we wrap
this up but the last two minutes of this
film I was like no there's too many plot
holes there for what yeah don't mind it
being spoil for you I'll tell you what
I'm talking about talking about the
exact ending okay like the final moments
of the hospital okay you bought that oh
yeah and the music is really is really
cool in this - it's a it's not an overly
invasive soundtrack it's not you know
it's not like insidious words and I like
that that's core but it's not like crazy
all the time like it's really tensed
kind of percolating score and the way
they balance the sound cuz sound plays a
huge part is a design is amazing in this
and I love sound Dior movies you know
it's great jump scares - in effect
without relying on loud noises or loud
cut to you or something you know well
because this makes like this a movie
where jump scares makes sense because
everyone is like on high alert and I'm
trying to sneak a rat like that's just
the time for jump yeah yeah you know
like a nothing that happens at it in a
house late at night is not gonna be a
jump scare yeah it's more about don't
make noise so so when a noise happens
even if it's like a little noise you're
like cool I like that Momo
Dillman ed steps on the floor and a
little yeah it goes off and you're just
like oh and that's the thing too is like
in the middle of the night in an empty
house like everything is [ __ ] loud
and all this guy's doing is healing I've
been meditating a lot lately
and the more I meditate the better the
portion of my meditation gets where I
focus on I'm pointing out what I could
hear and really like discerning it and
knowing what it it like pointing out
even more details it's cool you surfing
like your daredevil
if you've ever had to sneak back into
your house in the middle than I usually
think anybody else just flashback to
that moment and then set a movie there
cuz you're like tiptoeing and like this
second you step on a loose board it's
like you free like you know apply that
tension then multiply it by delight yeah
the me this movies like panic or meets
hush yeah kind of and I mean they really
utilize the house they've he's really
creative about putting these characters
in all kinds of different situations
there's claustrophobic stuff there's you
know the darkness there's all kinds of
stuff they play with all kinds of
discomfort like fede alvarez seems like
he likes making uncomfortable movies and
it's shot with a lot of vigor it's
scored with just the appropriate amount
like it's distinct but not too much yeah
the actors are all on their a-game and I
think the dialogue has gotten better cuz
like Evil Dead I thought some of the
dialogue was a little was a little flat
it's gonna be a much bigger director
very soon like this in this movie I feel
like he needs a third film John and I
have this thing they're talking about
three films people need three films in
order to be established as great in
something yeah yeah like this guy's here
to stick around but yeah I mean he's a
third one
this proves like that he does have some
magic and and again it's like it was
what was so impressive you know like
when James Wan and Leigh Whannell went
from saw to I mean dead silence but also
you know insidious where it's like yeah
Evil Dead was gory and crazy and
over-the-top and and where is it a same
yeah it's an experiment in tension yeah
terror check it out I can do it without
the gore and I can make it
claustrophobic Nick it tends to make it
weird and off the walls like it's it's a
really vigorous movie yeah I think he
even said that I think he said
didn't want to do ghosts they didn't
want to do something super glory and he
wanted to do something that man imagine
all intents I want to see this again as
soon as possible I mean like I know a
lot of people bring up green room in the
same conversation like yeah if you
double feature those you'll just have a
heart attack
yeah I think this is its own unique
piece as much as much as there's like
like the the closest I think in terms of
anything is panic room in my honest
opinion I think panic rooms are closest
there's similarities doing things like
hush and green room but yeah but panic
room was the one where I'm like if
anything seems like there was an
inspiration directly from any of those
it was probably that movie it's a movie
where criminals break into the wrong
house but it's an exercise in you know
excellence in restriction and simplicity
and it's like yeah we've seen that set
up before but this is clue like they
thought about their story and how they
can make this version its own
interesting thing I think they succeed
in spades with that you know I think
it's I think it's terrific okay yeah out
of ten breaths I'd say take ten yeah
take ten breaths and and in call me ten
out of ten breaths take breaths do you
guys want advice on how to calm your
anxiety count to ten inhale is one out
Hale exhale out hail hail - so yeah the
app of the exhale is even number inhale
odd number you do it's a tenth then you
keep in your restart you do it like two
or three times guarantee you'll calm
down you would be right that's all they
had to do before see the link showed up
in the room but just calm the [ __ ] down
breathe it's pretty cold that's just
breathe guys have a new spoiler talk
please subscribe to this channel the
people who subscribe are the ones God it
sends to heaven that's right John John
reasons to Jerry Twitter and Instagram
handle and YouTube playlist and
facebook.com slash blue mouth social
media manager
that and really is running the shits out
of the real rejects FB and Twitter so go
support us there hmm and remember